hey guys do you know what kind of
hairstyles or
haircuts will look will fit in with your
specific
look it's important hairstyles are super
important because it changes
your whole appearance and also how
people perceive you
as a person but how do you determine how
do you know
what kind of hairstyles will fit in with
you
well there's a few things that you need
to look at you need to look at
your face shape you need to look out the
texture of your hair and also
the hairline so let's find out
what hairstyles will look good on you
i have a dream that's
all right now if it's your first time
here on my channel i'm daniel and
welcome
to dlm model lifestyle if you haven't
subscribed yet then please consider it
now let's look at what kind of
hairstyles will look
good with different face shapes there
are seven
basic face shapes round oval
rectangular square diamond heart and
triangular
now i'm not going to waste your time so
let's go through this quickly
for a round face the best hairstyles are
an undercut with spiky or messy hair the
quiff
the classic side part or any other spiky
hairstyle
why where are these specific hair cells
good for a round face
well because around face it's already
got soft
features so what you want to do is you
want to go for the opposite
you want to bring in these kind of
hairstyles that
sharpens their facial features the best
hairstyles for an
oval face are short sides and a longer
top
or a textured brush pack style or a comb
over and
undercut the oval face shape is very
similar to the round
face shape so what you want is a
hairstyle that will
sharpen your look next the rectangular
face
will look good with a top knot hairstyle
or a man bun you can also go for a crew
card with a mid fade
or an ivy league side part the
rectangular face shape is great
because it will fit in with most of the
hairstyles out there
so you can actually go and try a few
different ones next up the square face
shape it will work with a buzz cut a
short through cut
or a high and tight now the square face
shape is a very strong
face shape and what you want to do is
you want to go for shorter hairstyles
not medium to long hairstyles because
that will just steal the attention away
from your face
now for the diamond shape you want a
sleek bag or
a textured french top or a messy fringe
cut
or even better a brush up hairstyle now
if you can try to grow out your beard a
little bit and see
if you like it alright let's go to the
next one let's go to the heart shape
for the heart shape try a relaxed quiff
or
a long fringe hairstyle you can also try
a longer hairstyle like
shaggy haircuts because they can also
work or
try a messy top which will look great
now the last one the triangular shape
go for a very short pompadour or a
foxhog
undercut you can also go for an angular
fringe hairstyle
which will work great now before you
choose a haircut you need to look at
your hair texture
as well some guys got straight hair some
curly
then there's wavy hair afro textured
hair
fine hair thin hair and thick hair let's
take a look at
straight hair first now straight hair
works really good with
plastic hairstyles like the side part
with short sides
like the longer crew cut or the comb
over
or even the sleek back you can even grow
it long other styles that might work are
the quiff
man bun or taper fade now most guys like
myself who have straight hair can
struggle with
volume so what you want to do is you
want to focus on textured
layers and you can also use pre-styling
products like sea salt spray
and mousse to get some volume if you got
curly hair
you can either grow them long and let
them be or
you can trim them shorter to keep them
more under control with a fox hawks
or a crew cup other styles that will
wear tight curls
with undercut classic curls man bun
and also messy curls now let's move to
wavy hair if you have
wavy hair there's a lot you can do
because chances are you're not really
struggling with volume because
it's always there now you can play
around with this style but medium hair
usually works really good especially
when you have those nice layers of hair
some guys with wavy hair especially
younger guys
they like to just let their hair be
while others
they like to keep it styled but if it's
too much
to maintain medium to long kind of hair
then
you can just keep it nice and short
hairstyles that will work
are the textured crop side part wavy
surfer hair
short wavy haircut with fade long top
with
short sides a wavy fringe and a sleek
back
now let's move on to afro texture the
hair there's a lot you can do here
from a full afro to a buzz cut because
most styles will look really cool
there's a huge variety of barbershop
haircuts that you can choose
to look your best you can also try just
to grow out your beard and then just
keep it styled
to enhance your look for the hair you
can try a short afro high fade
a hard part with fade line up or
a clean shave it's all up to you let's
move on to
fine hair if you have fine hair chances
are you're going to struggle to get
volume
in your hair so use pre-styling products
that will give you the volume that you
need to style it
and then when you style it do it with a
textured
layered hairstyle for fine hair the key
is to add
texture so short textured hairstyles
like crew cut
short spikes or even an ivy league now
let's move on to thin hair if you have
thin hair which is of course very close
to fine hair
what but of course just thinner right
but what you want to do is you want to
go for hairstyles that will make your
hair
look fuller long or even medium hair is
usually a bad idea
go for a shorter haircut a short crew
cut comb over
or ivy leak that'll work great you can
also go for a bus cut
a sleek side part or even a short
textured crop now on the other hand if
you have
thick hair it can be great but it can
also be
terrible at times because it can be a
handful right so what you want to do is
you want hair
a hairstyle that is low maintenance if
you don't mind
the maintenance try pompadour or even a
fox hawk some people also go for those
cropped
hairstyles i personally think it's a
terrible idea but of course
it's your choice your hair but i would
rather prefer
more like a military style you can even
go
with short sides and a longer top if you
grind out more you could even go for the
viking look
while it's short on the side or shaved
other styles that will look great
are the quiff side part slick back
ivy league bro flow thick top or
a brush up now if you have a receding
hairline
you gotta try to stay away from long
hairstyles
especially if you have a long fringe
combine that with a big forehead and it
will
give people the impression that you're
going bald and it just looks terrible
when you've seen a lot of people when
they go bold
they some of them try to grow their hair
longer and then they kind of try to hide
those those
patches but people can see right through
it and it looks terrible
for a receding hairline you want to go
for short cuts
like a short brush up a brushed texture
a buzz cut
a widow's peak brush up undercut or
a taper fade now if you are slowly going
ball try to go for a clean shave because
it might look great on you
add a bearded style to it and see how
you like it
now if you want some more tips check out
one of these videos and i'll see you
there
cheers guys